okay I'll just get it out of the way
there's a picture of a naked woman in
this movie Disney is full of pervs they
are done now let's talk about the movie
the rescuers sort of along the same
veins of the Aristocats or 101
Dalmatians in that there's not much
magic not much stellar animation and
mostly just cutesy animals looking
cutesy though I don't think it's as bad
as something as the Aristocats there is
a little bit more story and character to
it nothing much really stands out about
it it centers around a little girl who's
being held by this evil woman who wants
her to go inside this mine and get this
incredibly valuable diamond talk about
child labor laws well it turns out
there's a big group of mice called the
rescued Aid Society that go in and try
to help people in such circumstances
definitely a creative idea I guess
though I guess like most people in the
movie I wonder what the heck a bunch of
mice can do in rescuing a bunch of
people but I guess that's the point of
the film it's no person too small yadda
yadda yadda so two mice named Bernard
and Miss Bianca go out to rescue her
while also coming across a bunch of
colorful characters I guess I remember a
few things that stood out like some of
the bad guys actually are entertaining
like this crazy lady who's holding the
girl looks like something out of a
1940's French bordello a really bad
1940s French bordello
her reactions a lot of the time are
pretty fun to watch she also has this
blathering sidekick a once in a while
gets a good line and she also has these
two alligators that are probably one of
the funniest things at the booth aside
from that it's just more accusing this
the little girl is obnoxious I can't
stand her she's like one of the Olsen
twins she's just designed to look
precious
really yeah if you click that little
Brandis paper again you're too sonic
yeah most of the movies just filled with
other scenes that drag or overly cutesy
or don't really see
to have much point or I don't hate it I
just don't remember it doing very much
for me even as a kid I sort of remember
being bored by it again with the
exception 1 or 2 comedic satan's not
really a fan I probably say there's much
better Disney movies you can watch and
what was up with that naked lady